I need your FAFSA pay for any
your parents tax information from 2015
2014 2013 a non-refundable check for
photos without a mean yeah this is
payback and I've been on my grizzy yeah
it says way back no sir
and now travel me back but guess what
huh let me tell you what I've been
through when it come to Sally she called
me at least twice today she won't on
money badly calling me from different
numbers
oh she say she slick but I got him all
memorized I hit it no quick
neither woman Bullock has a faithful
book so lots of car loans to feed the
boys graduate
it wasn't Megan quiet enough to pay him
back when his beef Oh miss my credit
I'll check my head full feds [ __ ] ain't
proud of that I'm more proud of that
ain't around in that I got two jobs
really got on my grind no time to whine
I can't ride the pine in the game right
now my sunshine start paying them nose
back one of the time got them down down
down down down down down down till I pay
them all alone piece and photos without
it mean yes is paid back and I've been
on my grizzy yeah this is weird babe no
sir and now travel me back but guess
what I did
love [ __ ] stop my crib yet you know I
just had a long day just got off of work
they got me drove my boss kept me late
walk inside the kitchen grabbed Edition
enough to play
grab the remote and turn on the news
open up my laptop I see that I got a
email from selling me did another month
that I forgot a pig oh no hook this
email a drama they say congratulations
I'm paying back your story Lowe's
I took a free shot but I had to save my
life
this is payback and have been on my
grizzy yeah this is way back
no sir and now travel evening but guess
what I did
hey my god I thought I told you bring
him back no fool
one
just me no